it's a Wednesday PFT ot some things that
we either didn't discuss during the
program things that we want to talk
about a little bit more and with Antonio
Brown I spent a lot of time talking
about it on the radio side we spent the
first full segment at the TV side
discussing it touched on it a few more
times Chris but I want to be very
specific now as it relates to what
happens next because today is the day
Antonio Brown shows up for work shows up
for practice walks through those doors
those doors that you have explained you
go through it it's very intimidating and
awe-inspiring how does this extra
wrinkle this very serious layer these
allegations of sexual assault and rape
made in civil lawsuit not in in a
criminal court how does that affect
Antonio Browns introduction officially
to the Patriot Way I don't think it's
going to affect it a whole lot again
this is not a team they're not gonna
make an announcement in the team meeting
and being hey everybody here welcome
Antonio Brown let's all give them cheers
for being a part of the team it will be
business as usual in New England there's
just nobody bigger than the team it
doesn't matter who you are even Tom
Brady and a workday Wednesday it's a
workday Wednesday now the thing that
might happen that's different in New
England maybe than most days or with
most new players I would think at some
point today or maybe this happened
yesterday there's a sit-down with a
member of the Kraft family Antonio Brown
and Bill Belichick to at least hear his
side of this story
and dive into this a little bit but I
think that's the only thing that'll be
different in New England they will go
out of their way not to pay attention to
Antonio Brown or not to pay attention to
the recent allegations and they will
just try to focus on football like they
do better than anybody we've ever seen
and moving forward the league will
investigate the situation the Patriots
statement from late Tuesday night
confirmed that and there's nothing to
wait for there's no criminal process to
which the NFL should feel compelled to
defer they could easily contact the
lawyer representing Brittany Taylor they
could set up a meeting with her almost
immediately egged me with her Friday if
they want to you can have somebody fly
to wherever she lives I think she's a
resident of tennis
see sit down and talk to her get her
side of the story get any other evidence
that they need talk to Antonio Brown
they can move as quickly as they want to
and there is a device available under
the personal conduct policy for putting
Antonio Brown on the commission or
exempt list if they decide based upon
the preliminary investigation there's
reason to believe that he is guilty and
this is a he-said she-said unless there
is some independent evidence that tips
the scale one way or the other it's
going to be what she contends what he
contends and how well their stories hold
up under cross-examination that's going
to be the question and the NFL is going
to delve into that probably if not
immediately pretty damn quickly because
they're on notice and there's no reason
to wait and she's ready to cooperate
that's one of the big flaws Chris with
the NFL's in-house justice system they
can't force people to cooperate so if
you just say I'm not talking how can you
ever properly investigate but when you
have someone who's ready to talk and
when when someone is motivated to get
justice through that process like a Zico
Elliot's ex-girlfriend was that's when
you have a problem if you're the player
yeah she's ready to cooperate I would
think the NFL's interest level is as
high as possibly can be I mean for two
reasons one this is the premier you know
franchise at all a football with the New
England Patriots right and then we were
all expecting them to be back in the
Super Bowl conversation and to it's the
hundredth season in the NFL and so far
it's been the hundred season of Antonio
Brown and the NFL I mean that's all
we've talked about since the start of
the league year in March I mean he is
hijacking the hundredth season to where
yes I think this is a special set of
circumstances with the allegations with
the history the player the fact that he
is on a Super Bowl team the greatest
team we've ever seen and it's such a
spotlight on the whole scenario that I
mean the NFL I'm glad they're acting
fast here and getting involved in this
and and hopefully we they getting can
get to the bottom of this and figure
this situation out a little bit and and
let's not forget now look let me just
say this these are serious allegations
and Britney Taylor is entitled to her
day in court
but to the extent the NFL is trying to
make us think that it has its own
independent court system it really
doesn't PR is what drives this bus and
there was a time where the PR interests
of the NFL favored being very aggressive
in the investigation and discipline of
players we have noticed more recently
the NFL maybe not being as aggressive as
it's been maybe realizing that it's
better to have great players available
play football than it is to come up with
reasons to not let them play so that's
going to be a big part of this as well
and I think the NFL needs to decide how
big of a PR issue this is before
deciding how aggressive to be with
Antonio Brown and again it's a serious
accusation and it may be obvious from
the first meeting with her and the first
meeting with him that one side is
telling the truth and the other side
isn't and then it allows you to make a
reliable decision on the merits but if
this one's closed Chris I think if it's
closed they're gonna be more inclined to
just move on and not do anything it's
gonna have to be obvious that she's
telling a compelling story saying all
the right things doing all the right
things to convince them that she's
telling the truth and he will have to be
a bad witness and based upon interviews
I've done them in the past as a chance
is gonna be a bad witness just because
when you start asking him tough
questions I don't know that he's going
to hold up well and that may come off as
proof of not being honest or complete or
trustworthy in his account it could go
against him and then they have to decide
what they're gonna do and if they
believe that he raped this woman you
don't just suspend him six games I mean
if they come to the conclusion to the
end of the day that her accusation of
forcible rape against Antonio Brown is
true and correct how do you let him play
football again right I mean yeah there's
no way you can there's no way I don't
think another team even if this even if
he's proven not guilty and a lot of
things come out of it just look shady
and just not looks good I mean he's
already doing the high wire act was
staying in the NFL I mean like we've
already talked about a lot this is the
only team I think that can really manage
him I mean I know Seattle was interested
we've heard that but I would have liked
this scene that I'm not so sure Seattle
could have managed him up there this is
a totally different culture and he is in
danger of ruining
everything and if they are true
everything does deserve to be ruined
we'll see the question I have for you
Mike does the NFL you think send
somebody up there to New England today
tomorrow to start talking to Antonio
Brown right away no or is this one of
those things they go they see her first
and then at some point they go see him
you know not not too long after that
remember last year when it came out the
the NFL had yet to speak to Kareem hunt
right who was accused of assaulting a
female in a hallway at a Cleveland hotel
and the video came out the Chiefs cut
him and then months after the fact the
NFL said we haven't spoken to him yet
the explanation was you don't confront
the person who's accused of wrongdoing
until you've gotten all the rest of your
investigation completed so I think
they're gonna talk to her first
and there may be some things they talked
to her about they need to nail down
through other investigative means
eventually they'll talk to him and and
how quickly they move along with this it
remains to be seen and there's another
wrinkle to all this as well the fumes of
deflategate are gonna hover over this
because it's one thing for the Patriots
to say we're not gonna comment any
further while the NFL has an
investigation pending well once the
investigation is done are the Patriots
going to agree with the outcome or are
they going to think that Antonio Brown
is being railroaded by a vindictive
League office that doesn't like the fact
that he filed a couple of helmet
grievances doesn't like the fact that he
is co-opting the hundred season of the
NFL I mean it doesn't take much to pick
that scab off of deflategate and have
the Patriots taking the position that
this guy is being accused of something
you didn't do it's a it's a much more
delicate and troubling subject matter
than taking the air out of footballs
that's for damn sure
but we can't rule that out because we
know that that acrimony was there four
years ago with the way the NFL handled
the investigation of Tom Brady for
taking the air pressure out of the
football so you know there are a lot of
factors here based upon what we've seen
in the past with the NFL and the
Patriots relationship and given that
that these investigations from time to
time haven't been perfect how do we
really know what Antonio Brown did or
didn't do and when the standard is that
low is anyone really going to have a
of confidence without some sort of clear
corroborating evidence which may not
exist if you don't have and may may not
be possible how do you win it out what
how do you corroborate a year and a half
after the fact that this occurred so
yeah this is gonna be a tough one in the
NFL yeah very very delicate a situation
for the NFL and the NFL is going to be
guided by its perceived PR situation how
people are reacting to it what people it
shouldn't be but the NFL will be this
entire mechanism is part of the PR
operation and Chris they're going to be
paying very careful attention to what
the fans are saying what the media is
saying what the expectation is for
dealing with Antonio Brown before they
make that final decision yeah well
perception becomes reality more times
than not and Antonio Brown that's the
other thing you know he's not gonna win
himself the benefit of the doubt the
taut the tie will go to everybody else
the tie is not gonna go to Antonio Brown
if things are like ooh this is a you
know we're on the fence whether you know
we should do something and take option
or not I mean I think with all the
actions that he has done in the way he's
acted you know on and off the field for
the last two years especially that if it
was closed like that I would expect the
NFL to err on punishment for Antonio
Brown because of his prior actions I
think that can come back to hurt him on
this type of scenario but definitely a
delicate situation and something I know
we'll both be keeping a close eye on
taking it back to football the Patriots
this weekend play the Miami Dolphins in
Miami a place where the Patriots are one
and five during their last six trips to
South Florida Chris I know you're theory
about it's a vacation to Miami and guys
sometimes aren't as focused as maybe
they need to be something's in the water
down there this is a real vacation this
time Mike this is a real vacation
they're just going to go down in suntan
and then go oh we got to play football
we're just gonna suntan why we play
football is that cool and they'll still
win 18 and a half points right is the
spread now via the Westgate Superbook
and look last year remember week three
the Vikings were 17 point favorites over
the bills and the bills didn't just
cover they won the game right are do you
have any belief is there any path
through the weeds that results in the
dolphin
somehow shocking to Patriots well
shocking would be that they keep it
under 18 points I think that's really
that's where my level is here I am too I
do think it's you know it's a
possibility they can cover the spread
okay when the football game absolutely
not I just don't see how it happens this
this Patriots team is talented let alone
it's really well coached and the the
ones that one way I'll look at it and
just go that it could be interesting for
two reasons for the Dolphins one these
are human beings who were highly
embarrassed last Sunday by the Baltimore
Ravens so it's going to be almost a
desperation type effort here in week two
and then the second thing is you know as
we've seen this is Brian Flores he came
from New England he's gonna understand
why formations and plays and threatens
certain things are called just like we
saw New England last year have a hard
time with Vrabel and Matt Patricia so
that is always an interesting angle but
I just think they're too far out man to
actually win a game like the Titans are
Lions did last year against the Patriots
and remember the big concern coming out
of that win by the Ravens over the
Dolphins was that the coaching staff
didn't adjust once Lamar Jackson was
picking the defense apart they don't
give safety help over the top they'll be
watching the players will how the
coaches handle this what kind of a game
plan are they gonna have how flexible is
going to be how much is bryan flores and
the other assistants with ties back to
new england how much are they going to
reflect their knowledge of the systems
in the game plan and how flexible will
they be if new england gives them
something different than what they
thought but you hit the nail on the head
last year was matt patricia early on
Mike Vrabel later in the season who took
down the Patriots and Brian Flores has
the knowledge but he may not have the
horses but again the Dolphins are five
and one over the last six years against
the Patriots in Miami it's just
something to watch and uh and I don't I
don't know that I'm ready to say it's
gonna be a complete and total blowout
what we'll see but I you know it would
be a hell of a story if the Dolphins win
this one straight up like the Bills did
a year ago when they were 17 point
favorites in Minnesota alright former
Bills running back LeSean McCoy
now with the Kansas City Chiefs he got
an up-close look at the Chiefs offense
he's
it was nice watching how fast they were
going up and down the field how much
space they had how many opportunities
they had Ellis Sean at some point it's
got to be we not they you're on the
Chiefs now anyway the gains they were
getting each play at one point in the
game oh then it becomes week we were
averaging like 15 yards per touch
that's not normal it's not normal and it
should help LeSean McCoy you know to the
extent that they're trying to figure out
what they do without Tyreke Hill hey if
everyone's focused on stopping Sammy
Watkins Travis Kelce in the passing game
more opportunities for LeSean McCoy to
prove that he's still a great back Chris
definitely and I still think he does
have tread on his tires there's some
juice left in those legs I mean I saw
enough in the game the other day to just
go damn okay I mean if there's a little
crack or a slither to get through
LeSean McCoy still has the shakes and
the explosion to get through it yeah is
it the same guy we saw four or five
years ago no it's not that guy but I do
think that he's gonna have a nice little
role carved out for him in this offense
Mike especially like you said now that
Tyree kills not there this is just
another weapon that he could that's he
Andy Reed can implement it in the
offense and he'll make up for maybe some
of the lack of Tyreke he'll plays in the
offense McCoy is super talented I mean
we know he's awesome in space running
the football but he is like a de facto
slot receiver as well he really is I
mean you could pit he could play slot
receiver and be a starting third
receiver in the NFL and run all those
option routes and jerk routes and be
trusted to read the coverage and run
precise routes and always be on the same
page as the quarterback and the
offensive coordinator and I think you'll
see that role kind of grow as we go here
with LeSean McCoy as well Michael and
consider this week one against the
Jaguars LeSean McCoy ten carries for 81
yards 8.1 yards per attempt Damian
Williams the guy who was presumed to be
the the starter and the workhorse 13
carries 26 yards 2.0 yards per attempt
McCoy added one catch now Williams had
six so maybe that's where he can
compliment the passing game up for
LeSean McCoy ten attempts 81 yards a
great start for him he had a long of 31
but when you've got the the the middle
of the field cleared out because they're
they're chasing around Sammy Watkins and
and the rest of the targets in the
passing game it does create
opportunities for LeSean McCoy to slip
through and do damage Chris yeah it
definitely does and and Mike you know
the other thing that just jumps out to
me his vision as her running back is
just it's off the charts that's where he
has an uncanny ability to send his body
language one where oh it looks like he's
gonna run through this hole he's gonna
run through the C gap and then he
without looking will just put his foot
in the ground and cut through the B gap
and there he just he creates a hole to
make it even bigger for himself because
of the way he can a cut adjust on the
fly stick his foot in the ground and
he's just got a great way about him and
he truly is like a point guard with a
killer crossover out there on the
football field but he I would think we
continue to see that role will probably
see Damian Williams and LeSean McCoy on
the field together at the same time
splitting roles doing things like that
but they'll find ways to get him get him
the ball in his hands that's for sure a
couple of years ago then Saints running
back Mark Ingram took a face full of
beer in the first quarter of a game at
Buffalo and afterward I talked to him
and he he laughed it off he said my
helmet smelled like beer for the rest of
the quarter but hey I got a free beer
and the guy had to go buy another beer
logan ryan the titans cornerback wasn't
as amused when he took a face full of
beer now he jumped up into the stands in
cleveland which kind of invites it not
that i'm saying it's okay don't jump up
in the stands though and your chances of
getting a beer in the face are naturally
reduced he wasn't happy about it he
called for punishment and the Browns
have indefinitely banned the person who
threw the beer into Logan Ryan's face
from the stadium and indefinite that
that just means we haven't determined
how long it's gonna be it sounds worse
than it is it could be two weeks it
could be two years it could be two
decades we just don't know at this point
but you know it's not acceptable for
fans to act this way I don't know why
people think they buy a ticket to a game
and they can just go be idiots and say
whatever they want shout-out profanity
that you've never shoutout in any other
public place I mean think about that you
go to an NFL game the stuff you hear
people say you would never hear people
talk like that anywhere else know except
you except well yeah it's
it is probably you're right I mean it is
an in yeah I at least I when I say it
I'll be there to where we can have
access and we can talk about it face to
face you know it's almost like the guy
who like likes to MF you and give you
the finger and does all that things when
you're in a car right because he knows
like uh nobody's gonna get out the car
and beat me up I'm driving 70 miles per
hour on the highway I can be just the
[ __ ] I'd like to always be and I feel
like that's what fans do when they get
to a football game let alone they have
the beer muscles to go along with it
they've thrown in you know four or five
beers in the pregame and now that the
game has started there's another few
beers and yeah people lose common
decency and that's I don't get either
Mike I would say to your point like
visiting teams come on don't jump in the
other teams crowd I mean of course
things are gonna happen with you know
70,000 idiots in a stint in a stadium
like that and you're rubbing in their
face that's not cool
but also to the fans come on it's one
thing that hey you stink or you know
we're gonna kick your butt when people
start saying racial slurs or throwing
food or beer on people that's just going
too far and we're better than that and
let me tell you I would not I I
appreciate the fact that thousands of
people pay for tickets go to NFL games I
would not do it not really out in the
crowd I've been there I've been there
it's no it's hostile it's loud it's
aggressive it's not worth it
it really isn't worth it I want to take
my I have yet to take my little boy to
an NFL football game right like I'm real
he's he's been to Super Bowl 50 but he
was like five years old and really
didn't know what he was at I there's a
part of me that wants to take him to the
Jets Patriots Monday night game a few
weeks from now and because you know I
want him to experience real football
with the fans and a stadium going crazy
my kids have yet to do that because I'm
of course working on Sundays most of the
time yeah dad's got pool get a sideline
pass maybe maybe that's the way to go
that's a-- but i feel like you got there
hey just make sure he doesn't get in the
way of their official yeah yeah thank
you yes and you know he says he grew up
with me he's heard all the four-letter
words on the planet already so I figure
him sitting with a bunch of Jets and
Patriots
fans he'll feel right at home so there's
a part of me that wants him to
experience that part of the football too
you know when I grew up in the 70s the
f-bomb never was dropped in the house
but pretty much everything else was and
of course we were expected to never say
it even though we heard it all the time
yeah something too and if you did say it
you got a shoe it not not a shoe in the
face but he did get speed look it was a
different time I wasn't abused everyone
was abused yeah like in the 700 now yeah
I know now you got to be ashamed of you
know spank your kid and I want to be a
girl
I've spanked my kids you haven't raised
the Sims we're kind of stubborn and
stupid so build up fill up every now and
then needed a little reminder when he
was acting bad all right before we get
ourselves in any more trouble than we
already have today let's call it Chris a
new episode of unbuttoned coming up I
may do a PFT p.m. podcast later today
we'll see how the day goes
we'll see you tomorrow for another PFT
live everybody have a great one see ya
[Music]
you
you